Some people look at the employees as the
last line of defense. I I I don't
hold this opinion. I don't think that we
should
rely on employees to be the the ones
that are holding or preventing the the
organization from falling into the those
traps. You should keep the the basic
cyber security, information security up
to date, what we call cyber hygiene.
make sure we have a if someone if
someone fell for the for the scam and
and that we you have a a malware coming
into your system, you need to have the
the right tools to detect it and and to
eradicate it. So it would be it's nice
if some if few employees really remember
what they what they heard in the
training in the awareness training and
and report things but uh I don't think
that you should rely on them because not
not because they not because they are
not reliable but because it's not their
job they have they have their their
daily job they are overwhelmed with that
and and some one in one of the one of
the awareness training that we did not
the training but the drills the
exercises that we did. One of the
managers said I rely on the
on the security professionals to prevent
it. So I I go I come to work in the
morning assuming that you do your job
and I'll do my job and if I let clicked
on something and something bad happens
it's your your fault not my fault.
[Music]
Shuki Pelleg, welcome to the human zero
day. I'm so excited for our
conversation. This is going to be so
much fun. How are you?
>> Very well, thank you. It's Thursday. It
can It couldn't be better than that.
>> Couldn't be better than that. TJ Tuki,
so happy to have you here. um because
the the work that you've done over over
quite some time really falls in line
with with the world that we're going to
talk about. H you've been in the
security space for a very long time.
I'll I'm going to let you go through the
entire or or a majority part of the
history because I would love to
understand your journey better. but also
you spent a very significant of time
being CISOs of financial institutions
like the International Bank of Israel
and uh that's a that's a pretty uh um
pretty large feat and today you're
you're still operating in in similar
contexts but looking at the looking at
the larger space and advising and
consulting and um and I would love to
hear from you Shuki a little bit about
how you got into security why did you
stay in security and how has your
journey your own journey evolved here.
>> Okay, let's let's begin at the
beginning. I started my my computer
road map in the in the military
us mainly with mainframes which is the
last the previous
decade or more than a decade last
previous century even into security. I
the actually the first time I had to do
something with security was still at
that time with the first access control
systems to mainframe computers and that
was around 1982 but that was an episode
no one called it security at that time
they they called it something something
else
after a long career with IBM in in
Israel and and in the United States I I
I moved to a company to a startup
company which is which was doing
security systems, security technology
and joined few people that I I was in
the army with them and that was actually
the first time that I really was
involved with security software and
security
procedures and after that in in with
with other companies I did mainly
security that is related to
infrastructure and to what's called GLC
governance
and the and the in compliance.
Actually the recent recent jobs that I I
held was the CISO of the first
international bank of Israel. It was not
the international but the first
international bank of Israel. It's for
it was for about 10 years.
>> Clarification. Thank you.
>> It was for about 10 years. Before that I
was the security manager for e
government which is was part of the
ministry of finance at that time and
before that also another security
position with
let's get let's call it a government
agency
and now after being responsible to to
maintain the security of an organization
I I stepped stepped away a little bit
and I'm I'm consulting to security
regulation
agency which is much more broader but
less less stressful.
I I love it and I love the uh much
rather less stressful. Tell me a little
bit about why security is exciting for
you. you know what what does it mean for
you to be for 10 years the chief
information security officer for the
first international bank of Israel?
>> It's a very dynamic job. It's something
that changes every day. It forces you to
learn and and get up to speed of new new
technologies all the time. It's not like
being a program coal programmer on
mainframe or a C++ programmer or a a
Windows CIS admin.
that can learn something and and stay
with it for a year or two years, 3 years
maybe more. With this in the security
space, it's it's something that is
changing all the time. And when security
switched to cyber, it even got faster.
So
when I look at again there there was not
much difference between information
security and cyber security the
beginning just to to make a marketing
differentiation and try to bring in more
new people young people to to the to the
industry but it it really succeeded and
now we are in cyber security.
The basics are the same but the pace is
much faster. the the environment is
changing all the time. We we are dealing
with things that we didn't even think
about doing them a decade or two decades
ago where we were managing information
security like intelligence reports like
looking at geopolitical
actions and activities that happening
worldwide and how they impact our
security or our security posture. And I
think that the dynamics is the is the
most important thing for me.
I I give lectures or presentations about
security every couple of weeks or or
months depends on on the audience that
is requesting that. And every time I do
the presentation, I have new new
examples, new scenarios. It's it's it
never I never have to to go back to the
examples and information I had with me.
a month ago or a year ago I was doing in
the past while I was working for IBM I
was doing workshops around the world for
IBM products and I had those
plastic slides foils that I could carry
with me and and and do and make the
presentation and I could use them for
two years the same slides. This is not
this is not the case with security. you
have to to change all the time with the
with the activities and with the changes
of the industry. So it helps you stay
young.
>> It I love that. And so let's stay young
with with human security, social
engineering and fishing. Um you're
saying you're mentioning that security
is is constantly evolving. It's
constantly changing. You have to remain
up to speed. How has the human element
in security evolved or changed over
time? And how has the experience of the
human element changed?
>> It really depends of of what which part
of the human element you're talking
about. If you look at the human element
as layers in layers you have the experts
you have the people and I like to call
it to be
involved or to be
say that influenced involved and and and
aware the the public should be aware of
security. the the the regular computer
users should be involved and the and the
technical specialist needs to be part of
the they they have to be to to to
interact and be really part of the of
the security. One one word one sentence
that security manager or CISOs like to
say all the time is security is
everyone's responsibility. So this is
nice. This is one way to try to shift
the blame to the users and to the
customers when something happens because
it was it's everyone's responsibility
and if something wrong happened it's not
only our fault it's everyone's fault and
no one is taking the responsibility and
in politics you see it a lot right now
but uh but it's actually it's it's a
real statement because
the security breach can can occur from
the
mistake take or ignorance of almost
everyone from a specialist that is doing
a misconfiguration or a user that is
clicking on the wrong link or someone is
doing an interview and downloading a
software that is not not even checked
like like me for right now.
How and and have you found you know
during your time that the attacks have
evolved or they've changed in some ways
because
there there's the common thread of we're
click we're clicking on links and SMSs
and emails and stealing credentials but
has the space changed at all? Yes, it
became more sophisticated or more
reliable or I not say reliable but
you can you can you can trust more the
interaction with with the fraudster
because they use better language and and
they don't send you
messages that are that are easily
discarded.
And this is the the human this is the
human aspect. But if you're talking
about attackers that are attacking
systems, this is something completely
different. And I'm not going to address
it. They they really got much more
sophisticated.
It's and they're exploiting the
vulnerabilities much faster and and
there's a race between the system
administrators or the system managers
and and the and the vulnerabilities. We
used to have vulnerabilities are coming
let's say every few weeks and then we
fix them we patch them and we we we do
the the cycle again and if if you know
the if you read the the the book the
story the little prince the little
prince goes one one day goes to the
the planet of the of the lamp lighter
and the lamp lighter complains that he
used to have a very convenient job. He
used to turn on the lamps in the
evening, go to sleep, turn them off in
the morning and and on on and on again.
It took 24 hours and now now the planet
is turning once every 1 minute and is
all all the time is doing all off to for
for the for for the lamps. So it's the
same with the with vulnerabilities and
patching. You don't have time you you
get to fix one one vulnerability and the
day after you may get two more. So they
are really having a very hard time
keeping the system safe and keep keeping
the system secured. And if someone is
negligent in in doing the patches and
and the attackers knows what
vulnerabilities are still there
especially old ones that were never
addressed during the time
they can fool employees or customers
into downloading software or clicking in
the wrong place and exploiting the
vulnerabilities. So it it's getting much
much harder and of course with the
advancement in in the tools for doing a
imitation the what we call the the deep
fake or not even the deep fake the AI or
chat GPT really helped in in taking all
the me the messages the SMS messages and
and the and the mails and the creating
them in a very
professional way. So you cannot identify
anymore and a mal malicious message by
bad language or by bad grammar.
Everything looks very very nice and very
clean. And and the next stage of course
is the deep fake in with with
video. You you you can even get
deep fake messages in conferences. You
can get fooled by them as well. First of
all, I don't know if you are real right
now. I'm not sure.
>> We'll we'll find out. I'll tell you
later.
Now, how have organizations
dealt with this this rising threat over
time? So, what I I imagine that you
don't don't just sit back and say,
"Okay, I'm going to let my employees
fall victim to these on an ongoing
basis." What do you do to help make sure
that the employees either don't get
exposed to the threats or if they do get
exposed, they know not to click on them?
>> Well, I I don't Some people look at the
employees as the last line of defense. I
I I don't
hold this opinion. I don't think that we
should
rely on employees to be the the ones
that are holding or preventing the the
organization from falling into the those
traps. You should keep the the basic
cyber security, information security up
to date, what we call cyber hygiene.
make sure we have a if someone if
someone fell for the for the scam and
and we you have a a malware coming into
your system, you need to have the the
right tools to detect it and and to
eradicate it. So it would be it's nice
if some if few employees really remember
what they what they heard in the
training in the awareness training and
and report things but I don't think that
you should rely on them because not not
because they not because they are not
reliable but because it's not their job
they have they have their daily job they
are overwhelmed with that and and some
one in one of the one of the awareness
training that we did not the training
but the drills the exercises that we
did. One of the managers said I rely on
the
on the security professionals to prevent
it. So I I go I come to work in the
morning assuming that you do your job
and I'll do my job and if I let clicked
on something and something bad happens
it's your your fault not my fault. And
there is something in what we what they
say because be they let something into
the organization and we didn't detect
it. So it's it's a shared
responsibility. We we fed a little bit
and they fed a little bit.
>> Absolutely. But but how does that
account to the situation in which they
fall victim to the attack in the
personal world in their external world
right? I mean I have my own personal
device. We're seeing these attacks go in
on WhatsApp now and and on Facebook and
and so they're beyond the perimeters of
the organization. So how how do you
think we should mitigate that?
>> Well, I'll go I go once again to a very
old TV series, The X-Files, which the
statement was trust no one and and trust
no one. That's be suspicious all the
time. Keep in mind that that it's every
place some there are there are fraudster
or scammers that are trying to to get
the advantage of you and if something
looks too good to be true may it pro it
probably is and and and
even if you are very careful and and
doing taking all precautions that you
you should take sometimes it will happen
and if you if you if you identify if you
if you suspect that you fell for a scam.
Don't be ashamed. Don't be Don't Don't
Don't feel like a victim that needs to
conceal that.
Report it. Report it to wherever is the
the right place. if it's the if it's a
Facebook or or the or Gmail that you
that you suspected something did not
wrong happened, but also you need to
make sure to take care of yourself and
and use the the additional security
features that all the platforms are
providing multiffactor authentication
and and the and the
looking checking all the time if if you
are if you are the only user in your
environment and they provide all those
features.
But it takes a few minutes or a little
bit time to use them and people should
do it on their personal in their
personal systems as well.
So Shuki let's look a little bit into
the future and um putting your
consulting and advisory hat on. Things
are changing rapidly. It's becoming
multi- channelannel, more sophisticated.
How where do you see the biggest
innovation coming or or where do you
think the biggest innovation should come
in the context of fighting off these
threats in the context of enterprises
banking systems etc.
Now what enterprises are supposed or
should do is to incorporate risk risk
scoring systems into all of their
processes and activities. So they can
identify a a risk while it's happening
and see that if if there is an anomaly
that is that is occurs in in their
system. if it's if these are
transactions or if these are
simple
interactions with with social media and
alert the user if if the if the risk
score is very high they should maybe
stop it them by themsel and sometime
sometime you get a false positive and
and and the person gets upset because a
session was cut or or a transaction
didn't go through and and they need to
provide additional information but But
that this is the responsibility of the
organization to provide more information
and and to wave the flags when when they
when they think that something is wrong
and and it definitely depends on the on
the on the risk appetite of the
organization. Some will be more
accept more risk some some will not
this is one thing that the other thing
is to to deploy
try and find and deploy more systems
that do automation and and definitely
see how how can AI and the machine
learning help in defense because I
believe and it's not only my belief it's
a it's a there was a survey with many
CIOS and CISOs in in Europe done by the
the World Economic Forum and most of
them believe that the AI will first help
the attackers before it will help the
the defenders and we definitely need to
take this in mind keep this in keeping
this in our mind and and and suspect not
suspect everyone but suspect
look raise our suspicious bar. Let's put
it like that.
Absolutely. Shuki, I really want to
thank you for taking the time to join
me. This was a pleasure and a privilege.
Thank you for sharing the insights,
wishing you best of luck and continue
making a positive impact. And thank you
very much. Thank you very much.